[inaudible]
can you cheat your way into
ketosis? The answer's yes and no.
I've been asked a lot recently
about different ketone
supplements, exotic genus,
ketones. All right.
These are externally synthesize ketones
that you can consume often in liquid
form.
Good way to remember exact genus XL
like exoskeleton outside endogenous that
would be ketones produced
in the body. For instance,
if you fast and then eat one meal
per day for two or three days,
like a salad with a little bit of steak
in a bunch of oil and you walk a lot
during that period of time, drinking
water, chances are in two or three days,
especially if you're a male,
typically to drop in faster,
you'll probably get 2.7 or higher
millimolars of Beta hydroxybutyrate BHB as
measured using a device called the
precision xtra x Tra by Abbott Labs,
which is what I use and I recommend people
use something like that with blood as
opposed to urinalysis
with the Quito sticks,
which as you get better at processing
ketones in your body will give you a false
negative. It will say
you're not in Contoso,
but let's come back to the
exhaust ketones. A lot of
my friends have said, hey,
have you seen this? Have you seen that?
It seems like I could just consume this
to get the benefits of Ketosis and while
I'm consuming my normal diet and a,
there is some evidence to suggest
that you can derive certain benefits,
say, uh,
related to anti-inflammation or otherwise
by consuming exaggerates ketones even
in the presence of carbohydrates.
However, and I'm not a doctor,
don't play one on the Internet,
but I suspect at least the more research
should be done related to the longer
term, say for a few weeks,
consumption of exogenous ketones while
you're eating a normal carbohydrate
dependent diet when you're using
still glucose as your primary fuel.
The only place in nature as it relates
to human physiology that I'm aware of
where you observe both elevated glucose
levels and elevated ketone levels is in
a state called Quito acidosis,
which is a dangerous state, uh,
observed. Typically I believe
in type one diabetics.
So if then we are mimicking
that by consuming exaggerate
as ketones on a regular
basis.
It's hard for me to see how that is
beneficial and strikes me as somewhat
epistemologically arrogant
as [inaudible] might say.
For us to believe with the limited data
that we have that that is a good idea.
I would prefer to be conservative and
I am a conservative personally in that
respect.
It's often just ketones can be a
fantastic tool for greasing the skids and
helping with the transition from
say a semi fasted or fasting state.
Perhaps you're using intermittent
fasting like I mentioned,
to consume one or two small meals a day
that are key to genic diet meals on root
ticket ptosis.
You can use the exoticness ketones to
give you some fire power and actual
cognitive ability in that normally very
gray zone until you click in and get to
say 0.7 1.2 1.5 millimoles, at which
point you'll be off to the races.
But otherwise I've decided for myself
that I generally steer away from it.
That doesn't mean that, for instance,
if you have depressed glucose levels
and you've just come off of a nice big
sleep and you had an early
dinner the night before,
perhaps in those circumstances,
if you're about to do exercise,
say aerobic exercise, you could
use ketones to enhance performance.
But caveat emptor, I would say be careful,
and as far as I'm concerned,
it'd be conservative.